Another Regeneration milestone was celebrated
recently, as large crowds gathered for the
official opening of the Kaiapoi Riverview
Terraces and boardwalk
with Mayor David Ayers cutting the ribbon.
It’s actually exemplifying what we’re
trying to do through the Regeneration programme,
not simply repair what was broken during the
earthquakes,
but actually take Kaiapoi another step forward.
The opening was timed to coincide with the
return of the
Kaiapoi River Carnival and Boat Show.
We haven’t had a River Carnival since around
about the 90s,
and it’s really good to see activity on the river again.
And of course, that’s what this redevelopment
of this part of Kaiapoi is all about,
in getting people back onto the river.
A huge amount of work was completed in recent
months to get the terraces ready.
Wooden decking was laid, a competition-winning
poem was installed
and Māori design elements were sandblasted into the steps.
Down by the new coastguard building, dredging
was completed to allow for the installation
of the first pontoon.
A second, larger pontoon will be installed
between the Riverview terraces and wharf
later this year.
And with the adjacent commercial development
now also open,
Kaiapoi’s Marine Precinct is starting to take on a life of its own.